Servilia it's great to see you here for
the premiere of penny trade for what a
fantastic series it is and what did you
enjoy most about living back in that
Victorian era and what did I enjoy most
about it um well I suppose telling the
stories about a more kind of feral and
soulful Victorian London and no way is
it shiny and bright and kind of
perfectly clipped and managed its or its
kind of the underworld and I kind of
like to see it in that way you know it's
people living with disease and it's
people living with demons and people's
lives being short you know as much this
shows about anything about the kind of
supernatural elements and the horror and
stuff I think it's actually to me it's
about a group of people who it's about
being mortal and all mortality and I
think that's why it will be appealing
now of course we're taking literary
characters and literary monsters and
bringing them back to life in this army
as well as mixing them in with new
characters so how are you keeping it
fresh for yourself as an actress and
also how is it keeping it fresh for the
audience
I suppose I mean the materials there you
know there's it's it's so well written
and so well crafted by John Megan who is
you know he's really really smart and
lively so and and and I think that he
kind of does that that work for you
earlier and I think this reading the
script it's like it's that kind of
insatiable experience you know there
that was part of the appeal for me that
I actually lived she couldn't put the
script down and I'd have to say 77% of
the time you could put the script down
so this was this was a rare beast and so
every day you're just turning up in
you know thrown around and here's a
course such a fantastic writer he did so
many films and this his first foray into
TV got the team behind bond on this John
Sam Mendes of course he got either he
was in kathena well we've got to lead or
would you like to be in a future bond
really what kind of heart would you like
to flow I could handle bond such an
enormous terrifying beast I don't know I
wouldn't be a Bond girl that's for sure
I mean I don't I don't make the grade
but I was maybe some kind of crooked
villain some female villain something a
bit slightly wild and unpredictable
maybe finally what do you think about
Pisco party were very shortly gonna see
him as doctor who won't wear what do you
think he'll be like he'll be amazing
obviously because he is amazing and also
he it's I just think it's a really wise
choice it's a perfect mixture of you
know comedy bones he's very very funny
but he also has that terrifying wild
kind of nature and in these performances
I don't know he's like as a person and I
think that that's gonna be a winning
combination
you